summer in the city and the economic
temperatures rising
higher inflation higher taxes and higher
interest rates the bank of england
voting for the fifth successive meeting
to increase bank rate this time up a
quarter percentage point to 1.25
the highest level since 2009.
that means higher interest costs for
those on floating rate mortgages and
loans
i know we've got to chat on the phone
we're looking at a five-year deal
now rates have risen yeah since he moved
liz and tony's three-year fixed-rate
deal expires in october they want to
lock in a deal now before rates go any
higher we did notice the rate rises
um
but again
i can remember a time when the interest
rates for mortgages were 15.4 percent
now i can't see that happening in the
next couple months
i might be wrong
so you know if if we can get our new
deal sorted before anything goes really
silly i'm hoping that we're just
catching it at the right time
and as more families come under pressure
britain's financial regulator says banks
need to do more to support those who are
struggling we know that uh people have
already been affected by the pandemic
and a number of people inflation is
rising uh significantly higher than the
rest of us
some inflation is rising for 14 for
certain people and in those
circumstances for those who have debt we
want lenders to be have the right
systems and controls and people ready to
help support
those borrowers
for this textile company in mansfield
the main challenges are higher input
costs and labour shortages all of which
sounds quite inflationary our fabrics
our materials have gone up by 20 our
chemicals have gone up by 25
even the sowing thread we use has gone
up by 15 if inflation carries on rising
like this then i have to put the prices
up again in the autumn and again next
spring and again next autumn because i
have to pay more to our staff and i'm
not going to let them down
it's worth saying that while 1.25 is
higher than we've seen since 2009 it's
nothing compared to the double-digit
peaks of the 1970s or even the early
2000s when five percent rates were the
norm
and after its american counterparts
raise rates not by a quarter percentage
point but by three quarters some
eyebrows are now being raised there's an
all saying in economics that it's a
central bank's job to take away the
punch bowl full of booze just as the
party gets going and around the world
other central banks like the federal
reserve seem to be yanking it out
quickly whereas the venerable bank of
england seems to be tiptoeing out before
anyone really notices
we know the risks too fast and
increasing rates could tip the uk into a
deeper recession too slow and the bank
risks losing control of inflation
altogether
then whatever it does the economic party
will end with a serious headache at
conway sky news